estelle est enceinte de sept mois sa
prise de sang de ce matin ne vise pas à
connaître son taux de sucre ou de
cholestérol mais son taux de chlordécone
une démarche pour la santé de son enfant
c'est de mon propre chef c'est important
de le faire pour l'enfant pour même
aussi et pour en savoir un petit peu les
changements de comportement quand je
dois avoir vis-à-vis de ce problème de
pesticides
ce matin ils étaient une vingtaine
répartis dans trois laboratoires à payer
les 70 euros nécessaires pour faire le
test le plus connu olivier bérisson pour
tous le but est non seulement de
s'informer mais par la suite de manger
plus sain aujourd'hui face à l'absence
de réponse des autorités dans ce
problème sanitaire du chlordécone je
souhaite savoir à quel niveau je suis
intoxiqués par cette molécule
et c est une démarche purement
personnelle mais aussi responsable
aujourd'hui on ne sait toujours pas
vraiment ce qu'on mange pour moi là on a
une solution concrète
l'association 0 chlordécone 0 poison
elle a demandé à des agriculteurs de la
structure organise par exemple de tester
leur sol donc on sait que quand on va
aux marcheurs gay pays on a des aliments
qui a priori sont sains mais moi c'est
une solution concrète voilà je trouve ça
concret et je trouve que c'est bien
aussi d'avoir des bonnes pratiques pour
mieux s'alimenter et c'est ce que
l'association propose le collectif 0
chlordécone 0 poison en effet recensé
les agriculteurs qui cultivent des
produits garantissant chlordécone le
parc naturel a également initié sa
démarche des initiatives encore
débutante et que le collectif espère
voir renforcée